hey I'll everybody and welcome to
another flippin video today we're gonna
be doing actually some free-to-play
content we're gonna be flipping some
higher level free-to-play items some of
these items I didn't even know we're
accessible to free-to-play players and I
realized that most people who have a 40
mil star won't be free-to-play so I know
this isn't totally realistic but it's
kind of for fun let's see what type of
margins how good margins we can get on a
free-to-play account so we have 40 mil
which I understand totally unrealistic
for someone to be free-to-play and to
have 40 mil and now there will be some
more lower level flipping content coming
soon but I'm just in the mood to do some
higher level flips and yeah let's see
what we can get from 40 mil so we are
having a look at the highest margins
here and I'm narrative down to a couple
items the team cape 0 which again I know
CLE was free play team Cape I the gilded
scimitar were probably good and the hill
giant Club and I think I'm gonna try
this arrow down when the kite shield to
start off I'll do the team cape well
team cape eye is very weird pricing
going on maybe you could leave an offer
in it maybe 1350 another thing I'm gonna
not do is only have access to three
slots all that's really gonna do is slow
me down I understand it's not truly free
to play because I'm using this seven or
seven eight slots that we have available
but free kind of just a quality of life
and to make myself not go insane I'm
just gonna use all the slots but they'll
only be free-to-play items so the start
off we'll try the teen Cape is 0
Oh x2 and actually no team K I will do
first and they will try maybe for 1331
and there's actually a decent man of
these traded per day and 1331 K
and I will try for three of these next
up we'll do the team Cape zero and it'll
definitely just put an offer in for
maybe thirty six eighty or something
team Cape
0:36 ATK it's a team right we do eighty
one thirty six eighty one cake and I
will do two of those we got 28 middle
left what was another item we wanted to
do the hill giant Club we could probably
get a 70k margin on that or so and
realistically we could do more of these
so check out the historical prices and
see if this is relatively low oh yeah
it's pretty decently low 1 1 7 7 maybe
he'll giant club 1 177 ok and maybe
we'll do 5 he'll giant clubs it's just
double check the price again looks good
and cheaper item I want to try was the
saradomin kite shield pretty good margin
for the price 10k on an item that's only
70 is pretty good try buying for 65 ish
surd omen kite shield 65 100 and that
will try for 20 of these and the last
step we might try some gilded scimitars
maybe just lowball an offering overnight
maybe for I don't know 7400 probably be
pretty good
yeah it's try 74
kilted scimitar 7405 kay and we can only
afford two of those I guess and we could
maybe try this team Cape X now this
seems to be quite on the rise recently
not quite sure what that is about
doesn't seem to be affected by trade so
much if anything actually increased
surprisingly and we will try bit for
1702 or something team K X 1702 K and
three will be good and yeah we'll come
back in the morning or a bit later and
see how many of these offers actually
complete so we actually managed to buy
most of the items the team capes zeroes
we actually bought last night before we
went to bed asleep opt those in to sell
for about a 200k profit and we did
actually sell one already
however selling them for thirty eight
eight seven and we bought them for 36
eight one so actually just a little bit
more than two hundred case pretty good
for free to play on top of that we
actually also bought five Hill giant
clubs I think twelve saradomin kite
shields two team Cape X's and we didn't
manage to buy anything kill the
scimitars unfortunately as well go ahead
and recheck the prices and the mall
maybe buy a couple new items so first up
we're looking at the team Cape X and now
it looks like it's kind of dropped back
down to 17-under but we'll try selling
it maybe for nineteen or eighteen
hundred still it could be nice to get a
200k profit but that might not be
realistic we will try for thirty eight
hundred or so would still be a nice
profit
alright so we're gonna pop it in there
for just under one point eight million
ah'd too bad but did drop down a little
bit next up is the team cape eye which
unfortunately last night you can see
that big blue spike in the middle there
that is what I was looking at last night
but they did not help help that price
unfortunately so we'll probably let's
see here maybe just try sell them for
somewhere around 1.4 mil - or maybe
thirteen eighty we don't want to dump it
for with the price set now cuz it could
easily go back up and well well that's a
year thirteen seventy nine maybe
and for the hill giant clubs that we
bought them for one one seven seven so
hopefully would still some for about
twelve thirty the margin isn't as good
on the hill giant clubs that being said
they do trade a substantial amount more
than most of these other items so it's
like three times the volume were getting
there so it definitely would make sense
have a lower margin I also dump them in
there for 1234 hopefully and maybe get a
40 or 50 K margin on each one and last
up we have the tsardom and kite shield
which we bought for 61 maybe or remember
anymore I think it was less than that
but we'll pop him in maybe for a 69 K
and safety cell and we bought them for
65 yes I'm not the biggest margin but
that's okay and we'll come back when
these items have sold all right guys we
were back and we sold pretty much
everything he's he'll join clubs who did
to have to reduce bit and they're just
selling off now the team capex we'll
start with that sure we sold it for
thirty five point three point six mil
and we bought it for 3 point formula
that's 200k profit pretty decent the
team Cape zero is actually a very good
margin on them we sold them in two
different parts but still for a pretty
hefty profit we got sorry we bought the
team Cape zeros for three point 680m
sold it for three point eight fifty so
what 200k on each team Cape zero we'll
definitely do that one again the
saradomin that kite shields sandwich we
got there we sold them for 833 K and we
bought them for 781 case 100k I'm doing
some terrible math here 60 K profit
there so and next up is the team Cape
eyes we didn't get very much on that
because we ended up having to dump them
for pretty much the price you bought
them for realistically we got to them
for about four mil and sold him for only
forty one thirty so 230 K they're not
terrible and we're just not enough to
he'll giant clubs all right so what
we're looking for here is the team Cape
zero now it went from thirty eight fifty
five to thirty six
so we'll try buying it for 3690 maybe
team cape 0:36 90 and do three again
next up I actually found an interesting
item with the monk's robe top gee it's a
very expensive free-to-play item but
look at that margin five one two nine
into five four four seven there's a I
don't know probably 20 of these trades
of the day so it probably get one in an
hour - I will put an offer for 51 that
30 about monk robe wait a sec there we
go monk's robe was a top of the G yes
we're gonna buy it for 50 won 3-1 or so
50 won 3-1 and we're gonna try for no
three of these as well I don't really
have a better item to go with it right
now let's try the gilded armor set
because that's a pretty good margin and
actually is kind of an N market item
people do buy it for a free-to-play
freaky Canyon or something on them and
it will just is a mess we're gonna try
buying it for 40 - 30 how about gilded
armor set LG probably yeah and 42:34 -
30k and due to those and yeah we'll come
back well hopefully with some flips all
right so we're back and we have gotten
some insane margins on the monk robe
jeez look at these holes before we sold
for six mil and be bought for 5.2 mode
that has 800 game profit a under game
profit but let's take our hill giant
clubs first
Seifer is on history still here no but I
think we got about 150 kf2 a torso and
the armor sets we paid 8.4 mil for and
we did sell them for I guess
um let's at least buy each one for only
got about 50 km each of those so I'm not
too good and then but the monk robes
okay we still have one more to sell we
bought them for fifty five point two mil
and we sold one overnight for six
million won the previous day for six mil
and also a gilded two-hander we got
about a 300k profit on so pretty dang
happy with as well we're gonna pull that
out now and what we have left is the
monk's robe and we'll sell that off as
well now we just have a quick look at D
tracker and it looks like look overnight
it went up to six point three mil which
is what I thought about leaving it in
for but I just didn't but that's okay
we'll sell it for fifty nine forty a bow
okay now to put in some more buy offers
we're definitely gonna buy more of these
month robes and even if we bought them
for a little bit more that's totally
fine like 5301 that's still a pretty
good price 5303 kay and go for another
three of these because that is just such
a good margin okay on top of this I
think we're gonna try the regular monk's
robe
it looks like has a 300k margin which is
still really good for free play so we'll
try buying it for 2005 now let's put our
buy offers in the bottom this time
Sonics robe and 2005 K do three of those
as well that's right yep three months
robe and yeah they'll move on to another
item all right we'll try buying a couple
of these team Cape X's like look at that
margin that one mil I doubt we're gonna
get that but I'll try fine for 1799 1799
and oh do three of these it was as well
and it leaves us with nine mil all right
let's try behind this blue skirt gold
we'll try buying it for 47 K or so
loose Kurt g47 K and well do 15 of these
have a that's what they eat mill oh boy
we instantly bought them what what we'll
try selling them for at 61k still don't
see what how that goes alright and I
think we're just putting offering for at
the two hander against it has a very
good margin and we'll just try lowball
in it and I made 38 50 kilobit
two-hander try 38 50 k and just buy to
those all right we'll come back in
hopefully some of these items have
flipped
so these monk ropes are actually insane
we already bought another three of them
and sold them two of them already for
59:40 and we sold the other one we had
for 59 40 as well so off the first three
we bought we made one point eight mill
in free to play which is just totally
insane we bought another three like in
an hour and at under an hour pretty well
and that we already sold off two of them
50 59 40 we're gonna pull off these
items and just double down on these
monk's robes because they are so much
better to be honest we can almost afford
another three but we'll just go for two
for now and well maybe we'll check G
tracker again just to see if they've
change in price alright so it looks like
the sell price is up to 15 and 40 but
we'll still try buying them for 5303
that still seems like a reasonable price
it's 303 k and just do two for now and
that we also got yeah one of the monk
robe bottoms I guess for two mil pretty
well and I guess we'll pop that in to
sell as well looks like the monk robe
bottom is still going for about two
point three mil acid is still three mil
and profit just there as well which I'm
extremely happy about as well 22 to to
10 K and yeah we'll come back with some
more progress so we have finally
actually sold everything for once we
don't have anything left over this time
and we managed to get another set of
these microbes totally flipped so if we
claim this one
that's beautiful 59:40 if we look at our
price history here this is what we
bottomed for fifteen point nine mil me
sold them for a 17 point eight mill that
is nearly a two mill profit just in one
flip in free to play that's like almost
a bond like that's really insane I've
never had a flip even close to that we
also have this monk robe from earlier
I'm not sure if it's still on there this
is one of those that we bought for 5202
yeah one of these ones and then we have
the two monk robe geez we sold those for
a 300k profit each which is pretty nice
should be in our price history there too
yeah four zero one zero and two thousand
or - milli - I'll and we sold them for
2.3 m LH really nice there as well and
the blue skirts are pretty decent way of
a hundred K in profit or so but I think
this is where we're gonna end the
episode it's already in pretty long but
let's have a look how much we actually
made just doing some casual FreePlay
flipping we started with a 40 ml recall
and we're at 46 point 1 mil like hell
this is actually better than my almost
as good as my third aged Filipinas crazy
so it really goes to show that you can
flip in a free2play it really just
depends on how good items are and
actually doing some research into what
items there are available in
free-to-play for one because I didn't
even realize that half these items were
and yeah I hope you guys enjoyed and I
will see you guys in the next episode
[Music]